all right um you think correctly and um
hope the microphone works uh so i
this
anna could have not set this up better
you know having me follow the first two
talks um in in part because you know
decreasing complexity is good so this is
a lot decreased complexity from what
we've seen before but also because the
last talk was actually
um talking about administrative data
without calling them such and i
i
this talk is designed to highlight a few
more of the actual data analysis
challenges and
i'm fully prepared for you to tell me
that all this can be done and is solved
already that would be okay even i mean
it might look bad on me but if you tell
me that at the end the outcome is great
so i'm fully prepared on that um
unfortunately this beautiful picture is
not longer up on the whiteboard but for
those of you who've been here longer
have seen this before i'll use the same
scheme
as i did in my bootcamp talk but this
time focus on administrative data and um
i start with the end
of the five points that i want to make
and and that is that in the short term
we do need something that allows us to
analyze
administrative data in
in the clear if you will or in their raw
form and you know looking at kobe's like
i can tell he will not like that but
but um but
as far as i can tell it from what i've
seen so far and learned here in the
semester
currently we need that and
that doesn't mean it's open to the
public what i have in mind is
systems of various types you know
that allow for
a remote execution or a guest visit in
some
data facility but in that context i
think what we will
see
much more in the coming years um is is
the need to
put administrative data in such
environment in a big scale and what i
hear from john about and other folks
that um
get referred to as the elephant
in the room um the census bureau among
the federal statistical agencies sets
the tone and you guys will be setting
the tone and i think you will have a a
strong effect on the other statistical
agencies as well as the world and um
and i would like to use this session as
a discussion on how like
how far can we get go in that direction
you know without losing sort of you know
the the immediate data needs um that the
government has and
and some of you might remember i
introduced these two reports on the
outside here
in uh the boot camp
reports from the national academy of
science
that a panel that was designed to
look at
modern uses of
federal statistical model creation of
federal statistics
in a privacy protecting manner was
you know literally in the middle of
the time this panel met the
bipartisan commission for evidence-based
policy making was created and they
strongly pushed for
the opening of administrative data for
statistical purposes and to
inform
evidence-based policy making and
if you look at the recommendations in
there
there's a strong call to congress and
the president to enact
statutory changes that allow
that data for example data on quarterly
earnings and i'm pointing those out as a
form of administrative data because
that's what i'm talking about in the
german example later on
that they are made available and one key
feature of these quarterly earnings is
they are
often or i think in the u.s statewide
collected in germany other
administrative units but different
administrative units are collecting them
and um in in and they are collected
jointly but
currently rarely made available
for
research purposes
the reason this panel
met and the reason this commission is
focusing on that so heavily is that
their notion is that
if you were to do this with survey data
you'll end up in you know having too few
respondents to have reliable data and
i'm cheating here a little because this
graph shows
the development of survey response rate
from 1997 to 2016 but this is a
telephone survey from pew this is not a
u.s census bureau survey right but but
you know
the kind of decline is actually mirrored
in other
surveys except that they didn't start at
36 and went down to nine they started at
60 and or it started at 90 and went down
to 60. so you know the the the rate of
change is you know comparable but it is
a huge concern for all of us so i'm you
know while my bootcamp talk was all
about survey and the survey data
generation this is the reason why we
look at these other um data sources and
um for that reason
uh ray chetty who was uh who whose work
with the irs data was heavily featured
in the second workshop here um has at
some point uh a little account here in
sort of the the the usage of
administrative data in economics
journals for them
and and you can see they
gain in popularity but of course
somewhat restricted by what is available
what can be analyzed by whom
um since then a lot has happened uh the
um
the the governing bodies that were
called upon to create new statutory uh
or new legal uh grounds have acted and
there is actually now uh evidence-based
policy-making act that came into effect
last year and
it has all the keywords that were in
these three reports right it talks about
protection it talks about um
making the data available a push for
making data public unless it's not
possible you know a push for assessing
risk of the various data sources
to protect
and the data accordingly and and
most importantly a push for making
administrative records available and you
know in in germany
not quite at the legislative level but
from the german government um
released also in november of last year
the strategy for using ai
on the federal level or for for
governing bodies and there's a a section
in there that explicitly calls for funds
to do research on creating synthetic
they call it synthetic training data but
synthetic data sets using differential
privacy so i mean this is you know it's
gaining attention stuff is happening
right so so
the the push is in that direction and um
in particular with an eye on the
administrative data so i i do want to
talk a little bit about
the administrative data in detail so
that that we are we are getting on the
same page on what it means to work with
such data and
we you know the questions that i asked
you earlier is like what are the sql
queries that you are allowing for i i
closely tied to this so
the
the point i want to make here is that
unlike what we've seen and discussed in
survey data or the way that many of you
are not involved in data collection
might think of data
it's really very different than when we
deal with administrative data and so you
might remember
in the survey
setting we talked about at the boot camp
the gender generating process of a
survey that we
worry about the representation side we
worry about the measurement side and we
try to estimate the error sources at
each step and and and so on but
all of this
the way a survey is designed there's a
lot of opportunity to study these errors
because we all we plan each of these
steps and so we we have a good insight
in how much work goes into a step and
what are the errors that we encounter
and we can do experimental variations of
each of these steps to get an estimate
of the error and eventually can account
for it right
so in that sense both the experiments
and the surveys they are designed by us
which means we can you know we we know
pretty much what's going on sometimes
not well because we don't have money to
study but in principle
now
with the all the other data sources you
know depicted here whether this is
transaction data or social media data of
sorts or the administrative data that
come in forms
this is not at all the case right they
arise and you know bob gross um
he used to be the head of the census
bureau called them at that time organic
data they arise not quite organically
they're but but sort of right i mean
they they arise through a process that's
completely different from what we want
to do with the data afterwards right and
and you know
uh sargonic calls them ready-made
maybe that captures it a little better
it's sort of like having ikea furniture
that wasn't designed for the place you
own and then nothing really fits in
there right that's sort of the picture
that you have but what it basically
means is that
all the work we have to do happens
afterwards right so unlike in the survey
setting where time and money is paid at
the
spend at the onset here really the work
happens afterwards and so i want to give
you an example on what that means
i mentioned earlier the wage records you
know the income spells and employment
records
so
we have um
in the german context at the institute
for uh
employment research that i'm at we have
access to the social security
administration records that each company
has to fill out when they hire someone
at you know every time someone starts
working
or there is some change in employment
that um
that happens there's a notification
that
is being given
to the social security administration it
includes a couple of pieces of
information name age and um
most importantly uh your income
and if there isn't any change then there
is an annual report of that record as
well and the the sole purpose of this is
to calculate later on your social
security contributions so that
retirement benefits are sort of squared
away
um
what that means is that you have
for every entity
i mean a person in the sense right you
have a beginning and an end of an
employment spell
and
a wage record right now
i you saw it on the title slide the
three affiliations i have right i mean i
already i mean
only two of them are in the german
system but they're already two records
and many people who have much less
stable
jobs than we have and many people with
interesting
job histories they have a lot of these
employments you know that overlap
you know in spells that start and end or
they they i mean because you know they
have a job and then they have a side job
right or they they have a job that um
has a certain job title and then they
they the title changes they don't change
the company but you know a new
employment spell starts and and what
have you so the the record-keeping
system is not at all aligned with our
desire to sort of reconstruct life
histories or if we try to analyze
trajectories on what's the consequence
of a certain you know historic event
that you had childbirth or periods of
unemployment on uh trajectories later on
right and so
the the
the nature of these spells you know
requires a lot of
you know reconstruction of these
databases you know a typical one would
be this episode splitting that you you
know try to align the episodes and uh
create additional cases so that that for
each time period you know
what are uh the actual employments
what's the um
the employment level if you will and and
so on
so
what this means is that
in in your case with the medical queries
right the the sql career that you
mentioned how many people have a rare
disease right
it's a very difficult question to any of
these data so how many people are
actually employed right is not an equal
and an easy answer to get just by
putting out a query right
and and
for someone who knows the database well
it's fairly easy you could construct an
sql query to do that but for a
researcher who
doesn't know the data well who just has
that question they wouldn't even know
how to begin asking or writing that
query without being able to
sort of explore the data and see what
are the periods what am i constructing
here for a given research question
so
that's one element the second element is
that these data are all very spas
okay
so i mentioned the social security
administration data
they have
what is this i didn't count maybe 15 um
different elements here sort of scale of
the census decennial census 10 questions
right
there's not much information in here
very sensitive information because
income is part of it
but it is not very much and
what is interesting most of these down
here so
education vocational training
type of employment and
nationality are actually incredibly
sparse they are filled with missing data
they are they never get updated because
the people who fill out the forms all
they know
to care about is putting an employment i
mean the beginning and the end of the
spell incorrectly and the value of the
income
but all of these other things this i
mean they happen to be on the phone
because someone decided that should be
on the form but there's no
administrative purpose for these data
and therefore no one checks whether
that's correct or not right and in
particular here nationality i mean many
of the migrants that come in um
eventually that changes you know might
not get updated in the system because it
has no consequence for this kind of
reporting system right
so what that means to us is that we do
or any researcher who works with the
data needs to link them up with other
data from other sources either to get
new variables attached to it or for some
where we know their particular week like
education or foreign nationality to get
better values in there than the ones
that they are right so
essentially these admin data as these
integrated employment biographies as
great as they are they basically have
three variables that are of interest two
of them you can't even see which is
first name and last name and then uh
it's only the the um
income that that you see
so what what happens often is that you
see
data products coming out of that agency
that are sort of a combination of survey
data and administrative data where these
additional pieces of information are put
in which means that the administrative
data are by definition a sample as soon
as they are linked up to some smaller
source they
they are a sample because no one can
afford to
survey the um entire
german workforce i didn't mention that
before but the records we have available
are um you know pretty much any
employment since 1972 that happened
every employment spell of someone who
was gainfully employed right so
um
so so this would be a typical example um
this is here the data are combined with
the survey uh that was done in companies
so you have company level information
you have company level information about
the particular employee and
their work environment and then uh
survey data from the the participants as
well so linking the possibility to link
on an individual level whoever does that
is another feature often this linkage is
not done by the researcher themselves we
the way we work with administrative data
is the is done by a set of 10 people
that are in the institute allowed to do
a linkage and see the linkage identifier
but everything else in the operation
happens in clear text
so
then
i would argue even if someone else is
linking it when you prepare the data for
analysis you can't do that independent
of the research question and um
you know let me give you two research
questions here to to illustrate that so
the
the first one is a a study that was done
here out of berkeley um by david khan
and others on this very data set that i
just showed you and the question was
does workplace that there generated
change um
wage determination over time so this is
you know
a
longitudinal study if you will right
they are
creating a measurement of workplace
heterogeneity defined as it may be
and then a definition of wage change
that they want to analyze over time you
could make the same argument for the
hospital records right you want to
create a measure that sort of uh
captures how the
the the the the composition of the
patients in the hospital and the ratio
of patients to
healthcare providers in the hospital
changes it
has a long-term effect on the health
outcome over time right and
and
i have a hard time thinking on how one
could construct that measure if all i
see is you know noisy data you know so
so that's sort of where i'm coming from
this other example here how do children
affect further employment trajectories
that was um the example that
colleagues in number did you know the
challenge they face here is you know
someone gets uh employed in in this case
you know we we don't know whether this
person is pregnant or not right the
record only shows you is employed but
then at some point in the employment
spell you do see
a notice period of six weeks right and
that notice period comes with an
indicator that um you know is sort of a
reason for leave you know code 51
whatever that means right uh you can
eventually find that out and uh but it
is not it is not unique it it is just
indicating that you're leaving for a
health reason so it could be you know
your maternity leave it could be you're
taking care of someone who is sick you
know in particular your child those are
administratively for the social security
system the same thing right so that's
why this is not differentiated so what
you need is sources from an external
database because there are different
pots of money that get distributed to
these people depending on the actual
reason that you can apply for so once
that's linked you can get a better
specification on um a possible maternity
leave here
and um usually what you then see is that
uh an even longer period because that is
the maximum that this um
you know
can be used as maternity leave um
so this is the the typical spell break
you see before employment is picked up
again but obviously
only for those that pick up employment
again would you see that and get a
confirmation that this combination of
events likely indicates a child birth
and therefore indicates someone that you
could put in the set
to examine what happens uh
past um childbirth in terms of work
trajectory
and you know when i think through these
examples i wonder right if i if we now
think of we apply dp and i apply the
logic of you know
getting the same result by taking an
observation in or out right what is an
observation in this case right is it the
person is it a particular employment
spell that this person has is it this
event is it a combination of this person
working at a particular company
in this longitudinal setting where i
have so many spells that mean different
things you know it's not clear to me how
like what at which level are we adding
the noise and do do we do this
overall globally or
do we need to do this per analysis and
then the research questions are so
different from one researcher to the
next that it's not clear to me how one
would think of a privacy budget so
that's you know that's i've i've
tried to come up with ideas but it's
really puzzling to me
how
how to translate a concept that is so
charming to me on a theoretical level
into what i see my colleagues do there
in practice okay
so
you know they said i i do
unless you have good answers and as i
said at the beginning i am prepared for
you to tell me that this is all solved
um but
until we have that i my hunch is that
with this strong push that happens right
now at omb and you know around the
federal data strategy uh initiatives
that we see
where at a fast pace they do want to
make these administrative data available
we're not ready you know to to protect
them in a way except through these um
secure environments and you know
one of them uh is the the
administrative data research facility
that
has been built in new york but there are
many others you know this is the one i'm
most familiar with
they're particular trying to allow for
some form of collaborative modules so
that
all the steps that i mentioned before
all the thinking that goes into
understanding a certain spell into
creating code that you know
that transforms the administrative data
from one form into another can be
captured and used but everything that
happens in here happens in the raw on
clear data right and if i understand
john correctly
it's not that the census bureau here
would be entirely opposed to to this as
long as whatever happens then as output
gets
noised up in some form i'm not saying dp
because i'm not sure if that is the
solution that that is possible but but
but the the questions i have i mean the
problem i see coming up is that
the researchers that work in this space
have no idea how to do this piece right
and and so there's a clear need to make
that piece easier or give some guidance
on what should be done there currently
how we are solving this um with the iab
data there are a lot of um
remote access
points to access the administrative data
that i just introduced one of them is
here in berkeley um and what they're
using is a system that came out of
the the um
what is that stand for
the labor market research institute in
germany which uh name i forgot it but
that's yeah
um this one here iza um
they
they develop a piece of software that
sort of allows you know entering your
code you get the results back they have
some protocols on how much how many
queries you can send in which frequency
so that an input and output control is
possible um but you know here some
numbers on on what i mean basically the
fraction the turquoise numbers are what
needs to be manually looked at or can
only be partially automated in terms of
you know
checking the results and and deleting
input and and the blue portion is what
happens automatically right so i mean
this is about a thousand um
a thousand output products a month that
this team looks at but
you know this doesn't scale i mean if
you think about analyses and lots of
researchers clearly we would want to
move this bar up here or
enable the researchers to do this in a
way
that that
privacy protections are in place for for
their output what's really interesting
to me is unlike the us in germany for
most of these agencies including the iab
whatever the researchers at the irb do
when i want to publish something out of
these data no one is checking that for
me right i mean i'm
we're sort of expected to just magically
know how we publish these data without
compromising someone right but um that's
that's a whole nother discussion but but
even if we are thinking of a system here
like that where basically we are looking
for some way
to make um this bottom piece here
efficient out the noise only at the very
end you know for for me the question is
what what are
good ways to do that and and how could
we
you know
work on this in parallel by trying to
figure out how to uh create data dp or
you know put them out in a way that you
do because if for every administrative
data set that there is in the us
we need a team like yours
and the effort that you presented this
morning then i don't know if we ever get
in time to what the federal data
strategy is aiming for so
hopefully we can discuss this this is it
thank you
we have plenty of time for questions
or discussion or discussion
yeah so in addition to these um
1000 per month queries do you actually
have a sense of what
i guess people call the workload
like what are the questions what are the
i mean what's the nature of things are
they similar to each i guess one
question is how similar are they to each
other
um
that's a good question i don't know that
of the top of my head but i know the
project so and i have the figure i mean
the number of people and projects
they're working on is of course less
than than the number of outputs
the the outputs are not a query in the
sense
like
one query and one result right i these
are entire jobs written you know so it
could be that each of these has
you
know 100 queries in in the sense that uh
that you talk about or even more in
terms of similarity i would say they are
all very different and in part because
already at the beginning most of them
define the population they're interested
in slightly different right so the paper
about the workplace heterogeneity that
david cart here has done
they're restricting the set of people
that they want to work with to
male employed between
20 years and
however old
and only full-time employed because
the economic theory doesn't allow for
the messengers of the data once we move
past full time and below full time
employed right and the administrative
data just don't give enough information
on how much work is done and
and and so they just don't touch that so
their set is completely different than
this workplace mother said you know um
because they're leaving the females out
knowing that many of them are part-time
employed even if it's not recorded this
indicator for full-time and part-time
employment is very weak it's one of
those where the data are often missing
so so
i would say any of these studies
use a different definition
of the population and then of course
touch different variables they that's
what i mean there is not a single
measure that's created like so the race
and necessity variable it's it has a lot
of categories you know yes you have
six categories you know to the power of
two versions but that's nothing compared
to
a long-term wage record series with like
six different wages at any given point
in time over the course of a year some
overlapping some not and then trying to
really get the annual salary for i mean
it's
it this is easy you know i mean there
aren't many variations and and so i
would say very little thing very few
things that are the same but
it i i i will try to get a
quantification to very little it was
just like you know is there
an elephant
prototype that would one would want to
sort of attack first versus you know
a bunch of a bunch of mice or they all
get
gazelles or something running around so
how help me think through what that
would mean no i like i like the idea
that i love elephants that's why i had
to call the center for that before but
help me thanks for that idea what would
that
what
how could an answer look like to that
that would help us with this problem
right like is it a set of analyses that
everyone does and so you basically do
that first is that what you're doing
of people are really just interested in
linear regression
then you might focus your efforts on
trying to figure out how to
optimize for you know making linear
regressions sort of easier to do and
then you would say okay well then maybe
move
yeah okay so
i would say the set of
statistic analysis they're doing
that's more limited right so linear
regression time series analysis you know
some instrumental variable you know the
the econ toolkit on data analysis okay
increasingly machine learning but well
mostly sort of a limited set
but what is
not at all standardized are
creating the features to begin with
that's the problem i try to emphasize
right it's just it's just
i i can't see i mean and it's very hard
i mean even if you try to argue and you
know this whole movement of like
metadata and data documentation and
making this all more standardized it's
it's inching forward because the
research questions are so different that
everyone wants to construct something
slightly different with the data right
and i don't know how how this you know
the big tech companies you know how that
affects them but even there i would
assume that
the queries aren't always standardized
when you deal with the log data either
right i mean
the maybe there's a standard definition
of what the click-through rate is but
you know i'm not even sure about that
right so
but but for us it's certainly not the
case you know and that's that's why
dealing with these data that are
designed for a different purpose you
know there's many ways how you could
argue
you know some care about the daily spend
some care you know was like oh we're
okay with monthly you know
there is a lot yeah
so can you
tell us a little about what's happening
with these uh blue and turquoise parts
like how are they actually what's
happening yeah so um i do i was thinking
of putting that up on the side but then
i
um didn't so the um
so
so they basically go in and um have for
each
type of statistical indicator that's
created a rule what happens so let's say
for percentiles right when you when you
put out percentiles they say you know if
for if if you want to do run a release
amine they um
require that they're at least 20
observation behind if you want to
release the median they require 40
observation if you want to release
percentages
25th and 75th percentile you need 80. if
you go for
10th percentile
so that's
the dark blue side or the green side um
so
that piece um
i guess it depends on the text they're
trying to look at that and you know i
would say that's the the semi-automated
piece right where they look at and if
it's obvious then just just take it out
of a table right so anytime um these
criterias are not met they would take it
out of the table but then um you know it
um
yeah and then for for
um
for graphs to my knowledge it's all in
the turquoise part so uh plots plot
examinations i don't think they have
tackled yet to be
not even semi-automated from what i can
tell i mean well they're doing two
things right they're looking at the
actual code that goes in there and then
at the resulting uh tables or the
figures
behind a plot that um
that result in these and then they apply
i mean it's all rule-based you know what
they do there and then um what what
happens in the output code that they
either delete the cell entirely or
delete the last digit and replace it
with the stock in an output table
and that makes sense you know so
if it's too precise you know 162
you can't have that then they replaced
it last week
but i mean from all i've learned here
clearly not optimal right and not if you
do this repeatedly but um
[Music]
and that's why i'm saying i think
there's huge
opportunity to improve this not just by
automizing but also to do this entirely
different at the back end once you have
the actual analysis results but but that
but but i feel like a lot of the
discussion that we had here over the
semester so far is
at this point where
where the data comes in right i mean to
a user basically the direct um
where's the client well anyway the data
user here so that that we are trying to
find a solution for the direct movement
of data to the client right
and and do that in a private way and and
the the question that i'm grappling with
is for the type of data that we are
doing can we do this or do we need to
move them in something like this first
and then worry about how we um make the
the results dp rather than the data
itself if that makes sense can i ask a
little more about that
the next slide so for that again for the
green part where people are looking at
this
uh is any kind of risk assessment part
part of this and if there is
a risk assessment part then what does
that really mean
when would you call something a risk
assessment like what um so so there is a
class in there similar to what we've
heard um alex present um
you know this
like
reasonable effort class you know that um
they have i have not seen a
quantification of it in any of the
documentation that i looked at um but
i'm not sure if that's what you mean
with risk assessment so i saw that also
in one of your first slides there was
like one of the uh
principles was risk assessment i think
um
okay so i mean what what happens is that
um
i mean this is all governed by law right
in the the the regulation calls for
you know it can it has to be an academic
you need an institution that signs for
you and vouchers sort of on your behalf
there are large fines you know everyone
signs not to abuse the data and so so
there's a that piece similar to the
model that you had right that you you
have a compliant but curious user or
whatever the technical terms were that
you use there
and then um
and then i
they have um i'm not sure if i can find
that quickly enough but um
but then they have
for the assessment of the output data
they have the um
the same language that we've seen in
other places that with the reasonable
amount of computational power you
you're not able to de-identify the data
that's sort of how they phrase it with
without anything being specified and i
have not seen that being done or updated
i mean we're in the same boat uh as
census was like five years ago
so it sounds from what you said before
like
most of the sort of freeform
organization of things that that isn't
it doesn't live in sort of a nice
analytic space that's commonly repeated
by a lot of users is before the actual
analyses are done it's sort of how
you're chopping up the the data that you
have into whatever universe or view
whatever view of that data you're
interested in correct uh is there is
there any sort of set of common
operations that could be identified and
the way people are cutting that stuff up
that that could be concentrated on like
what it would be enough to be able to to
express generic sql operators over the
input data um and you know perform joins
that kind of thing in an efficient way
that's private and then give someone
access to that sort of privatized
language for doing so and then combine
that at the end into sort of another
step of dp that
before the final release
yeah so this is my question i mean the
the thing is that i
some of it can be
what i i wonder about though is in
in the production step at which point
would that happen right because when you
create some of these features that have
to do with the longitudinal nature of
that
the analyst
there are a lot of queries in that
exploratory phase you know the most of
the work is just exploratory right i
mean i would say all of these you know
poor economists they spend 90 on pretty
boring
parts where you learn nothing except
construct these measures right
and and so there are a lot of queries
that just serve the purpose to
understand how you can actually create a
reasonable
measurement out of that data mess that
you have you know and it includes the
way you know your decision on how to
impute the data your decisions on yeah
so so
that's why i'm not sure
if that could be done i mean it's an
interesting way to think about that you
know and maybe what we need to do is
take all the analysis code that they
have and see you know like maybe it is
more similar than we think right maybe
they're all taking the same
age group or maybe they should i mean i
think it would be reasonable you know
just like the tech industry you know
sometimes
they might break want regulations um if
we only would give them so maybe it
would be fine if we say you can only
analyze these data in the following way
at least for the basic demographics or
what have you i could see that but
what i'm concerned is like even that
construction of the spells like
stitching them together in the right way
i'm not sure if that can be standardized
and what would it mean if we add noise
ahead of time to that can you then still
do it
yeah
i'm just trying to understand a little
if you go back to that previous slide
uh yeah that one so
this is in the context of
you know locking room or whatever you go
in and you have access to the data in
the clear
and then you come up with some
statistical insights
that you might publish like in a public
policy correct journal
and then you want to release your
publication correct
that's the scenario correct
so
when you and i'm going to use the word
after schedule
cover dp and what i think obviously
is the question i mean is the
is this scenario that maybe you could
interject
more um less rigorous forms of
obligation because you already know
you're not trying to solve a very
general problem but you're trying to
solve a much more specific problem
and so maybe you could
interject
some obfuscation that's more specialized
that might not meet
the standard of ep i mean i'm i'm just
trying to
right so this is this this is exactly my
question like what would i tell
you know what what would i tell these
people right
what they should do at the end you know
here i have my finished regression table
and my
graphs right and and
what do i do at that point and
are these steps that that basically any
any user can down and then we could tell
all these rdcs
a publication can't be done unless i put
that on top of it and yes it will
increase your standard error and you
know make it less significant and that's
part of the discussion we have tonight
that's good you know so i think everyone
i think it's much easier to get the
whole community on board if we if we can
provide a reasonable solution to what
you just said and maybe that is an
easier problem to solve then trying to
get the community on board that that it
has to work here right and that they
can't do
all these steps that i talked about
before
prior
with the data in the clear right and and
so and so
so yes i think it could be an easier
solution i just don't know how would
that look like so that it satisfies um
dp standards i mean
well maybe not quite yet but it's
sufficient from from your obs of
suspension point of view and then why do
you want to use less vigorous uh
approaches
but you want to use something that you
cannot prove and usually doesn't work
what i'm saying is that
sometimes if you take something like
adversarial machine learning
the more you know about the circumstance
you you have greater capacity to
interject kind of noise
that will have like a radical impact
on how well it performs if you want some
generic way
then i think you have to have higher
highest
higher standards you can
[Music]
i'm not sure that's the right thing
because most people don't know how to do
that the researchers usually don't know
that but
still you have to do something that you
can do if you do something
it usually won't work it will be bad and
it
won't provide privacy
to be continued because yes next week is
coming up but
that's exactly the question